Russia's war in Ukraine is draining
ammunition stores on both sides
Western allies are scrambling to keep
arming Kiev while Moscow has ramped up
its production at home
but with the economy sanctioned the
Kremlin also appears to need outside
help
this is purportedly an arms contract
between Iran and Russia dated the 14th
of September 2022 it appears to be for
varying types of Iranian artillery and
tank rounds
they're listed on a table in batches of
a hundred worth just over one million
dollars in total
an informed Security Source said these
are thought to be samples for Russia to
trial ahead of a bigger deal I've also
seen a supplement to an allegedly
related contract from the same day look
you can see the signatures here the
value of the Munitions listed is around
000 and includes the barrel of a gun for
an artillery piece and for a tank now
the source that shared these documents
with me claimed they're 100 authentic
Sky News hasn't independently been able
to verify that claim we have approached
the Iranian and the Russian embassies
here in London but they've yet to
respond to a request for comment seeking
to confirm the veracity of the contract
Sky News shared it with Ukraine's prime
minister when he visited the UK last
month thank you so much we will research
this investigate this and and thank you
for this information a couple of weeks
later the Ukrainian ambassador to London
and gave us an update
as you might understand we are now
verifying the sources documents and how
credible the the document itself we
suspected that is something like that
happening as soon as we verify it
properly we will be able to act upon
this Sky News also showed the files to
the UK's foreign secretary during a
recent trip to Estonia will the UK seek
to verify whether or not this contract
is authentic well of course when
information is presented to us we will
look to assess it and to validate it and
of course we will make decisions based
on that no country no country should be
assisting an aggressor when it is
attempting to invade its neighbor
the UK and
drones to Russia for its War
punishment would surely follow if Tehran
has supplied ammunition to
Deborah Haynes Sky News